let's say I'm hanging out my buddies one
night and we realize that there's a huge
opportunity in selling socks online
socks online and so we decided to start
a company so the first thing we would do
is we would write a business plan and
say you know what in this business plan
writing process this is all we've all
contributed to it individually so we'll
all be equal shareholders let's say
there's five of us friends so the first
thing we want to do is we want to start
a well you know you could do it in
different orders you could just write up
a business plan or you can start the
corporation but what does the soom that
we start a corporation and I'm going to
indicate the corporation by kind of
creating a balance sheet right from the
get-go so what are the assets of the
corporation and what are the debt OS and
what are the liabilities and we could
talk a little bit about what a
corporation even is so it's asset to
begin with the asset to begin with is
essentially just an idea I mean you
could say it takes physical form into
some degree in the business plan but
it's just an idea at first and then
there are no immediate liabilities it
doesn't owe anybody any money and we
learned in the balance sheet videos and
you might want to watch the balance
sheet videos as a prerequisite to this
one but in general assets are equal to
liabilities plus equity all right so we
have no live so this is the assets the
only asset we have right now is our idea
maybe you want to add you know the
potential talent that we have maybe
unique skills they're very intangible at
this point unique skills these are the
assets that our 5 buddies have together
and we have no liabilities we didn't
sound like we borrowed money or anything
so everything we have so the assets are
equal to our equity our equity and I'll
do that in let me do it in a brown color
so there's no liabilities and we just
have equity and equity is essentially
what the owners of the company have the
right to for example if I haven't
assigned any numbers here that I did
that for reason but if the assets were I
don't know ten million dollars and
liability was five million dollars if we
had owed five million to someone
then you would have five million left
for the equity and that's what the
owners of the company would have me at
nine five buddies or like I guess my
four buddies we decide we're the owners
of the company so we'll have eat will be
equal shareholders so we would split the
equity between us five ways so we just
pick an arbitrary number let's say to
begin with we have a million shares so
each of these each of us have 200,000
shares in the company
and that's a bit of an arbitrary notion
and you normally do assign some value to
those shares initially you know it's
some pennies per share but I won't get
into the dick into the technicalities of
that just fair enough to say that we've
we each have 200,000 shares in this
company and some of them go to me and
then the rest I'm go to buddy one buddy
- buddy three and buddy 4 this is the
equity right here right and there's a
total of 1 million shares outstanding 1
million shares outstanding good enough
well you know just an idea and some
paper and some well-intentioned
individuals alone isn't enough to start
a company we're going to have to create
some type of own online presence and do
some programming and maybe have a
warehouse and do some marketing so we're
going to have to and and really we're
gonna have to quit our job so that we
can work on this full-time so we're
gonna have to raise some money money to
to hire some engineers
so that we can quit our jobs to hire
some marketing people etc etc so where
do we get our money from so this is
where the whole venture capital world
comes into the picture venture capital
and you've heard the word before and I
think you had some sense of what it is
and the venture capital world it's kind
of separated into different people who
invest at different stages venture
capital so you'll have people that
they're called angel investors and
sometimes these people won't even call
themselves venture
angel angel investors angel investors
and these are the guys that are kind of
these you know I don't want to
stereotype it but they'll be kind of
like the the the old guys who made it
big in the 80s and now they're sitting
on billions of dollars and they want to
participate in the neat
ideas that that young guys like me and
my friends think of and so you know
they're kind of like your rich uncle
says oh that's a great idea I'll throw
some money behind and they usually
invest at a very early stage so those
are probably the people we would go to
initially and then we'll talk to the net
to the people after that the other types
of venture capitalists but in general
the you know these things that venture
capital can mean a lot of things but it
means someone who's going to give you
money they're going to take a stake in
your company and hope that your give you
enough money to kind of get your venture
going to kind of start your business so
let's say we go to an angel investor and
we say hey angel investor don't you
think this is a great idea we're going
to sell socks online you know socks or
something people run out of it every way
we can even do subscriptions for socks
you know you get you get 10 pairs a
month etc etc you can give them as gifts
all of these lovely things and you know
the first the first nine guys slammed
their doors at our face you think our
business plan is stupid but the 10th guy
says hey you know that's that's
interesting so we enter into
negotiations and he's like you know what
I'm going to invest but we have to
figure out what I'm going to get in
exchange for investing in your company
how much of your company I'm going to
get and so this this leads to a process
of valuation so let's say we say we need
five million dollars from the angel
investor to get started right we need
five million dollars let me write that
down
five million that's what we say we need
and that's what the angel investor says
that he's willing to give us because he
agrees you know five million dollars
that's enough for us to quit our jobs
and then we could all take salaries you
know for some time we could hire a bunch
of people we can rent office spaces and
do everything you need to do to start a
company and five million dollars will
support that for I don't know a year or
two I don't know depending on how many
expenses we have but the question is
what does he get for that five million
dollars so in order to come to that
conclusion you have to determine what is
what we have before he came to the
picture worth right notice when I did
this balance sheet I didn't even write
what these assets are worth what is this
worth and this value this is called a
well in general whenever you're valuing
anything it's called a valuation
valuation valuation and since we want to
know what this is where this is before
we got any kind of money from investors
this would be called a pre-money
valuation pre-money pre-money valuation
and I'll show you why that matters in a
second
because if us and this angel investor
agree that this you know our assets
before we go to them are worth five
million dollars so if we agree that
they're worth five million dollars let
me let me draw that so what color was I
doing that in it was in yellow so if we
agree let me draw a little bit smaller
so essentially it's just an idea and
then we have the shares a million shares
of that million I have two hundred
thousand right the rest other eight
hundred thousand are with our with my
friends these are 1 million shares total
or shares outstanding so if this idea we
agree with the with the angel investor
if we agree that this is worth five
million dollars if we agree that this is
worth five million dollars so everything
we have today is worth five million
dollars then when he gives us another
five million dollars that's an asset
right we'll have five million dollars in
cash so he'll give us another five
million dollars he'll essentially get
fifty percent of the company he'll get
all of these shares up here now how does
that work out well if you think about it
this is this is the post post money
company right so let's think about it a
couple ways if this is five million
dollars that's the idea what is the five
million dollars worth and that's not a
trick question it's worth five million
dollars right it's worth five million
dollars so what is the post-money
valuation we talk about valuation we're
talking about the value of the assets
especially because we're not dealing
with any debt right now everything on
the right hand side is equity so this is
all equity let me write that no no
liabilities yet and in general when
you're doing a start-up company if if
you know I want to start if I want to
start start Sox online.com and I go into
my local bank and say hey give me a loan
this is they're just going to turn you
away because if you have a venture that
really doesn't exist yet and has no cash
flow they know that you're not going to
pay the interest on the debt so you're
not going to even be able to raise debt
until you're a more mature company or
until you you know maybe you could post
some collateral and I'll talk more about
that maybe you could say hey you know
I'll use my house if I don't pay the
debt you can take my house or something
like that but for the most part we don't
want to do that so the only way to raise
money at this early stage is by issuing
equity so going back to what we were
talking about what is the post-money
valuation we said before any of this
stuff on the top existed the pre-money
valuation of just our idea was five
million dollars now the angel investor
if we value this at 5 million he'll give
us 5 million more what is the total
value of all of the assets now well if
we said this was 5 million that's just
something agreed with this is worth 5
million so the combined assets if you
believe that this is worth 5 million is
now 10 million dollars right and this
would be the post-money valuation
post-money valuation and if you think
about it if you think about the the
company in this form right now we me and
my buddies we've contributed half of the
value of the company and this this this
rich guy he's contributed the other half
of the company so it makes sense that he
he has 50% of the company so how is that
going to work well I don't give away any
of my shares and neither are any of my
friends they're all going to keep their
shares so let's see we had five chunks
of $200,000 that went to hundred
thousand shares that went to each of us
all right that was buddy one two three
four what we'll do is we'll actually
issue another million shares and give it
to this rich dude so this is another 1
million shares so as the company board
you can actually authorize to create
shares and that's what we did and we
essentially sold those shares for 5
million dollars so now instead of having
1 million shares you have 2 million
shares so something interesting here and
some people often talk about the notion
of die Lucien right because before I had
200,000 out of a million shares so
before I had 20%
20% of the company and now what do I
have
well we've essentially doubled the share
count so now I only have 10% of the
company so some people says oh you know
what my share of the company got diluted
but it really isn't the case because the
company has gotten all this cash right I
now own 10% of something that's twice as
valuable as opposed to 20% of something
that's half as valuable if you really
believe that then this was no change
right
I now own 10% of 10 million which in
theory should be worth a million dollars
before I owned 20% of five million which
was also worth a million dollars so if
you believe these valuations I probably
I'm neutral and we're going to put this
five million dollars to work and
actually let me let me take a step
actually if now I just realized I'm out
of time let me continue this in the next
video